so delighted to be here with Dex Hunter
turturic of the Facebook meta I should
say oversight board
one of the most interesting and unique
experiments in one of the most important
areas the moderation of what we can and
can't put online Dex welcome good to be
here let's just start by helping me
understand the principles underlying the
oversight board so there are 20 people
on it why 20 why not seven what are the
core principles that underline the
design of it yeah so we actually we have
23 now we've grown a little bit um the
way we've looked at it is to make
decisions about content for a global set
of platforms Facebook and Instagram have
billions of users around three billion
we need to have members on an
independent body who represent the huge
diversity of that user base many
different backgrounds many different
communities who can help solve some of
those really complex challenges that
uses are facing every single day on
those platforms so our starting point
was really how can we get enough
different points of expertise that we
can make informed judgments about these
issues over time I expect the board will
grow large and we'll have more members
um adding to that so the the question or
the topic of oversight boards and
content moderation boards has really
come up recently because Elon Musk has
said that he'd like one for Twitter
you worked for Elon Musk
um what advice would you have for him on
this topic well look I think um
the first thing I would say when looking
at Twitter and how to moderate content
there is you have to start with the
principle of Do no harm and I mean that
in the sense that medical professionals
look at Patients when you make decisions
here uh you know four platforms like
Twitter which are part of the critical
infrastructure of free expression around
the world for you know many millions of
people including activists people who
are you know struggling for Better Lives
for democracy in societies facing
conflict the decisions you make in
California can be immensely
consequential and so actually making a
very rapid you know knee-jerk decisions
about the direction of content about
content policy that's probably not the
right way to go from the oversight board
perspective what we have you know
repeatedly you know encouraged better to
do with how they moderate content is to
be transparent about how they make
decisions
um really to show how they've come to a
decision so that it builds trust with
users
um trust in social media companies and
in business I I think has taken an
absolute rollicking over recent years
and certainly I think it will not be
helpful for restoring trust if you have
uh Elon making decisions where people
wonder is this being driven mainly
because of elon's personal preferences I
do think as well if you're building a
Content Council it has to genuinely
operate independently from the company
it cannot be something that just
reflects elon's personal preferences
yeah because as you
um refer to the key decision when meta
said it or Facebook as it was then set
up the oversight board was that Mark
Zuckerberg essentially stepped back and
said you take over this he didn't
actually step back all the way but he
did step back a little bit I mean you
know Elon Musk right does he have the
self-discipline uh the self-control
I I mean just does he have the character
to take a decision like that yeah I mean
um Elon is somebody who famously
describes himself not as a micromanager
but as a nano manager uh he's somebody
who uh often likes to be very involved
in things that are quite intricate and
you think other CEOs might not be uh
that invested in that element
um you know certainly um I think that
sounds like a no uh I I think based on
the last couple of weeks I think it's a
couple of weeks though it seems longer
um he is unlikely uh to be uh very
detached from these decisions we'll have
to see how it unfolds I mean I
understand that he's probably minded to
bring in another CEO to run Twitter so
he can go back to focusing on other
parts of his business
um interests and that would probably be
the right way to go I think Twitter
needs a lot of attention and if elon's
going to be providing that I wonder
who's going to be running the shop at
Tesla and SpaceX and just to say is that
essentially is that if the overlord of
the company is involved in a project
like the oversight board it can't work
can it
yeah I mean uh the oversight board
operates completely independently from
the political the commercial the public
relations interests of uh meta uh we you
know frankly don't care what Mark
Zuckerberg thinks about the decisions we
make
um we are there to advocate for users to
ensure that users are being treated
fairly um Elon does not need to be
involved he should not be involved in
making those incredibly consequential
decisions um I think he needs to take a
step back there needs to be policies and
processes that people can have trust in
that really allow this content Council
to operate independently okay Elon if
you're listening there you go some some
advice for free
um I want to talk about
um some specific cases but before I do
can you give me a sense of the scale of
the operation
um with just a few numbers so how many
cases have been referred to you or have
people
um made referrals by appealing to you
yeah so we've received over two million
appeals from users to date and a small
number as well from meta of those we've
done 29 big case decisions so 20 so 29
of 29. so why not more yeah so the way
to think about it right is we are not a
general customer service mechanism for
meta so we're not going to be in a
position to answer all of those two
million cases we could have 10 times as
many board members I still think we
wouldn't be able to answer all of those
what we're trying to do in each of those
cases is diagnose big underlying
systemic problems with Facebook and
Instagram which we then tell the company
to go away and fix so in those 29 cases
we also delivered over 130
recommendations of things that have to
change on Facebook and Instagram and the
companies agree to more than 60 of those
we think that's a pretty good uh batting
average all of the decisions we've made
about individual content as well the
company has committed to and they've
implemented what the board has told them
so just to pick up on something you said
there the company uh you've made 130
recommendations and the company has
picked up 60 I mean the oversight board
is often referred to as the Supreme
Court for meta but when the Supreme
Court says something the government has
to do it sure this isn't the case right
definitely we don't use that Supreme
Court framing others use it as a sort of
you know easy shorthand for referring to
this kind of body and I think the reason
they do that is we are a new type of
entity we are a self-regulatory body
designed to solve some of these
challenges within the tech industry
nothing like this has been attempted
before you know I think honestly uh the
fact that meta has agreed to more than
60 of those recommendations which are
very consequential which potentially
impact hundreds of millions of users
experience on the platform I think
that's a good thing um obviously we'd
like that they accept all of them but
baby steps okay and and just on the I
mean I know you're doing your best but
29 out of 2 million what about expanding
the board say to 40. yeah I mean uh over
time the board may end up being 40
members I expect will will grow over the
coming months but those 29 decisions if
you go and look at them and of course if
you go on our website you can read all
of those decisions in extraordinary
wonky detail they are very significant
changes to the platform you know just
one single example right um because of
the oversight boards work more than 800
million uh users of metas platforms can
now actually read the rules of those
platforms in their own languages that
may not sound like a big deal on its own
it's a single thing but it's an
important part of building transparency
and those 130 other recommendations each
of those is something that additive will
reshape the experience for users on the
platforms
are you having difficulty hiring people
because I know the ambition is to get to
40 are you having difficulty getting new
members because meta gets a final say on
who's on who's we honestly haven't had
particular difficulties with that I mean
we added the three additional members
just this year
um what we have been doing though is
taking a lot of time to determine what
are those extra points of expertise and
also to work out how scaling the number
of members will impact the overall
institution so because we are a new body
this is a new way of working
um those small changes which may sound
sort of self-evident they actually may
have outsized impact on the quality of
decisions so right now for example every
decision the board makes gets approved
by the entire board so that was designed
to prevent any single member or small
set of members from having an outsized
impact on these very consequential uh
issues um if you had 40 members instead
of 20
um obviously unanimity or a majority
there is going to be much more
challenging to achieve so it's working
out how to scale but effective I want to
talk about some specific cases because
once you get into the specifics I think
it is unbelievably fascinating how this
all works but first just to remind
everyone here that you can submit can
submit questions by scanning the QR code
on your seats or if you're watching on
TV or online then you can submit your
questions on Twitter using the hashtag
Big Ideas live22 right so let's talk
about a specific case a recent one can
you tell me about the case of the
Russian Nazi yeah sure so I mean this is
a very recent case decision that came
from the oversight board this was a post
uh in the context of the Ukraine
conflict uh where someone was calling
for death to the fascist Invaders and
that's and that's that's what they said
in their post death to the fascist
Invaders that's right um and there was a
an image as well as uh poetry I believe
in that case and this was content that
was removed by meta from the platform
and after the board looked at it we said
that was the wrong decision and actually
uh we required it to be restored
platform which the company did and the
reason for that is you had to look at
speech in the context of what was
happening in Ukraine an unlawful
invasion of a country with people in
Ukraine and many voices outside of
Ukraine are looking to support the
population there uh naturally
contextualizing the violence that was
taking place in Ukraine uh in the
context of other historical injustices
that have unfolded in Ukraine so in that
context
um actually we said this is perfectly
legitimate speech this is something that
in the context of a conflict is
something that should be permitted it
doesn't represent hate speech calling
for the death to the fascist Invaders
there in that context was referring to
Russian military forces who are acting
as aggressors so um that's one example
of a sort of very consequential free
speech in human rights issues we do and
if and if I understand the the case
correctly part of it was that the the
post said kill the fascists kill him
kill him kill him this is something of
course that would never be permitted
normally on on Facebook because one
thing you're absolutely not allowed to
do is make effects of violence but this
reference this killed the fascist phrase
was in a reference to a poem from I
think believed the 1940s and this level
of specificity is exactly what you're
dealing with so on this question then
you've in the end you decided that the
post should go back up
that took quite a while to decide
what difference does it really make to
anyone on the ground if in the end
you've decided that in this very
specific circumstance actually this one
relatively small post can exist yeah so
this is exactly where the
recommendations we make in those cases
do have an impact and I think they're
the most important part of those
decisions
um requiring meta to build policies and
systems that can understand that context
for guidance that they provide their
content moderators as they apply the
rules when they're looking at many
future instances of content that's where
we can truly have an impact so you're
entirely right on a single piece of
content it may or may be not be so
influential but in future cases because
of the board's work and the way we've
scrutinized those breakdowns and the
policies and the systems that will have
an impact for many many more people so
can you say then that the way that the
war in Ukraine is being talked about by
people on Facebook has been changed as a
result of the oversight but I think it's
something which will make a small change
and it will add up to a much larger set
of changes that meta has also of course
been doing itself since the conflict
began and you know they've had to change
a lot of the ways they look at content
they've had many new challenges that
have emerged in the context of that
crisis
um this is another contribution from our
side just to remind you you can all post
your questions
um please do scan the QR code on your
seat
right you mentioned moderation and I
think I really want to talk about this
because I think this is so important
other the practice of moderation so for
those who don't know
um a lot of moderation on Facebook is
done by algorithms it's done by by uh by
what some people call AI but it's really
just automated sifting of content and
then some of it is done by a large group
of people through Silicon Valley company
in other words really a very small
number of people given the scale of
Facebook
I think it's helpful to talk about a
specific case to get us into this so can
you tell me about the case of the
Brazilian nipple yes this is a case uh
that we took on a couple of years ago
now and uh this was a piece of content
on Instagram that was removed through uh
automated moderation by an AI system and
it contained a nipple and of course
Instagram has rules around nudity
um what the system did not understand is
that this piece of content was in the
context of a user raising awareness
about breast cancer and of course that
is something which the board when it
looked at that we said first of all that
is a legitimate thing which should be
allowed on the platform and subsequently
because of the board's decision
Instagram actually revised its Community
guidelines to allow that so we've taken
away that problem for users people
should be allowed to post about breast
cancer on Instagram which includes
images of nudity
um with AI of course there's a much
larger set of problems here which you
very rightly pointed out have been
exposed by this case yeah because
because just to say is that that post
that nipple which was put up in the
context of breast cancer awareness was
removed by AI it wasn't God so yeah so
what is it so okay so you made your
decision what does this mean in practice
then the AI gets reprogrammed
um the the the the the moderators they
get a little different line in their in
their book of of things they're not
allowed to put on that's exactly right
what happens that's exactly right so the
decisions of the board go back to
refining the processes and the way those
processes are enforced uh at meta and we
don't take the company's word for this I
should say we have a whole team on the
board side which we imaginatively call
the implementation team which studies in
depth how will the company implements
the board's decisions we report on all
of that publicly through our quarterly
and annual reporting so that is exactly
what is supposed to happen with AI
um obviously there is no future for
Content moderation on platforms which
have billions of users unless AI is part
of that you know talked about the
impossibility of any set of humans even
if we you know doubled or troubled the
size of our board to deal with all of
those problems so you do need to have ai
but you do need to refine those systems
and understand where they're breaking
down I I find that interesting because
to me reading the cases of the oversight
boards what really comes out is just how
important context is context is
everything
but robots or AI or whatever we call it
they're not great at contexts can
automation actually do this job in a way
that is fair to humans yeah I mean AI
has definitely obviously Advanced
enormously over the last decade it's
doing in a lot of cases a okay job at
looking at that context and of course
this is a lot of engineering work right
to build in the understanding with these
systems that can really pay attention to
very intricate social economic political
situations the backdrop of that content
but over time this is something that
absolutely is going to pose a technical
challenge it is something that the more
you get into very Niche situations you
understand the limitations of the
existing systems it's something we're
gonna have to solve and figure out what
the limits are have you looked at all at
the condition of human moderators
because we're talking about people here
we know from whistleblowers that human
moderators might be asking to make might
be asked to make a decision in 10
seconds they're exhausted they're
burdened by how much they have to do
many hours or some are suffering from
PTSD of the things they've seen
and these might be people who are
operating say in a war zone where in
fact there's been a war recently in
Ethiopia I don't know how many
moderators Facebook has for the
languages of the warring parties but I'm
going to guess it's not very many right
this strikes me as one of the real
issues for the oversight board in that
you might be delivering your high-minded
judgments
but they're being implemented On The
Ground by people whose working
conditions make it almost impossible for
them to do a fair job
have you investigated that yeah so I
should say uh we do look at how some of
those human elements of moderation fit
in with broader systemic issues at meta
so one example very specifically we had
a case from Myanmar uh where we found
that there probably wasn't uh sufficient
guidance given to content moderators to
allow them to look at content in the
language it was actually posted so our
guidance back to meta was you can't make
decisions in that way you need to ensure
that there are sufficient language and
translation resources available so that
moderators can actually look at the
content in in that language
um it is something that is a bigger
problem we've had some conversations
with uh folks who are representing uh
that community of human moderators it's
not a thing that has been the main focus
for the board and for that why not
because it seems absolutely key I mean
having audited the work of the modern
artists it's an important problem it's
not the one the board was designed to do
and we are very candid that we are a
small body designed to do one one thing
very very well which is look at content
uh and try to reconcile uh the policies
and the processes of meta with some of
its human rights obligations uh there
are other players who need to be
involved in solving these problems not
just us we're part of an ecosystem of
solutions this is where Regulators this
is where researchers this is where Civil
Society also come into into the picture
I mean but but
this seems to me not it seems to be
completely crucial I mean so again to
take the war in Ethiopia Facebook has
been implicated with uh amplifying the
violence by allowing hate speech on its
platforms ultimately if there are only I
don't know five moderators there for for
the for the entire um language of one
warring party
I mean I mean really this this could
this could cause really bad things to
happen yeah sure so uh you know I should
stress that is the sort of thing we do
look at so whether there are human
elements that contribute to the outcomes
that are being produced in these cases
but actually solving this is you know
for example looking at Labor conditions
for moderators that's absolutely
important problem this is not to deny
that for a second that's not going to be
the thing the board is going to solve on
its own and we need to be realistic
about the resources and the expertise we
have on our side fair enough thank you
very much right we have time for
questions now
um and we have a question from Colleen
Cotter
Colleen hello would you mind uh yes
telling us your question please if you
give give us a second wait for the mic
to get over
this I think a very relevant question
given what we were just talking about
um yes uh you're talking about context
so you're covering um some of that but I
just wondered how do you account for
Language and Cultural variation of
meaning that's you know you've already
been addressing a lot of that but I'd
like for you to talk a little bit more
about that thank you so a question on
Language and Cultural variation of
meaning
yeah I think you must have really
thought about absolutely so I mean
um for a very long time
um I think a lot of board members have
had a view that the way content is
moderated is often very uh Western
Centric and often very U.S Centric and
um if you look at any number of examples
of uh content issues in the global South
we've seen communities that are
repeatedly not well served by the
decisions and the policies of big Tech
platforms and so for that reason the
board has been very focused on looking
at Global South communities in
particular
underrepresented communities
historically who have often been
marginalized when it comes to these Tech
issues over half of the board's cases
today have been from the global South
um in those cases very often it is uh
linguistic and cultural Nuance that is a
critical part of that context that we
talked about and the ability to treat
users fairly and to make the right
decisions about content um and so um the
board itself is very very diverse you
know we've got 23 board members they've
lived in I believe 29 countries they
speak 27 languages
um we are constantly bringing in outside
points of expertise as well we have a
system called the public comment process
which allows any any person any of you
to contribute your point of view to how
we interpret decisions lots of Civil
Society organizations and researchers on
the global South are often engaging with
us on these cases and we engage with
them regularly so I think we're making
progress towards that there's still much
more work to be done though and I think
meta needs to do a better job there
thank you um and we also have a question
question from Chris Chohan I apologies
if I'm pronouncing that incorrectly
Chris hi can you can you wait for the
mic to come over and stand up and ask
you a question
thanks very much how can we yeah just
checking those work
um just on the topic itself as well this
I suppose in a bit more broader sense
you know as part of the oversight group
who moderates the moderators and
um how can we ensure that people see
this as uh trustworthy and effective
the big question who moderates the
moderators yeah who watches the Watchmen
um so uh one of the things that I think
is critical and this is certainly the
same advice I would give to Elon as he
thinks about this content Council
proposal is uh we are very transparent
about the work we do as well as being I
think often very western-centric uh in
terms of content moderation I think most
people would agree uh the way that
Silicon Valley companies have made these
big decisions have been very opaque um I
mean we're talking about researchers and
policy makers and Regulators even who
are really struggling often to
understand what's the rationale for some
of these incredibly consequential
decisions that end up impacting millions
of people's lives so um from our side we
put all of our working out in public
pretty much as as far as we can
obviously while ensuring that people's
privacy and security is protected in
some of these um communities
um the other thing we do is
um we are very very open uh and
structured about the principles and the
mechanisms we use to actually make
decisions within the board so you can go
and read our literal rules book for
members that's on our website you can
see our bylaws and how we're structured
and we also have an independent trust
with a set of Trustees who are there to
scrutinize the board and make sure that
we're upholding our mission we've got
another question from uh dino dino hiya
and yeah in the audience yeah if you
wait for the mic to come around yeah a
really interesting question hello I've
got a question really about Jeopardy
um so a lot of moderation is I guess
seen as invisible takedowns we don't see
it when it happens unless it hits the
news so the the personal responsibility
or the learnings for the the rest of the
users are sort of invisible so is there
anything is there any power you have to
reflect back onto the the platform to
put Jeopardy like to make people
responsible for transgressing rules or
is it just uh silent takedown is is is
where the future of moderation is yeah
should there be more visible signs that
someone's been sanctioned yeah uh that's
a that's a really interesting question
um I mean certainly
um there's a a piece of material that
we're going to be publishing over the
next few weeks on something called cross
check and cross check for those who
don't know it is the system that meta
uses to moderate uh in particular high
profile and VIP accounts on Facebook and
Instagram and this is a system that came
to a lot of public prominence last year
when Francis halgum the Facebook
whistleblower
um revealed uh some of the problems that
really are plaguing how that Crosstrek
system has applied so um in the
reporting that came out in the Wall
Street Journal first
um uh Francis Haugen argued that
actually the way cross-check was being
applied to content often spoke to behind
the scenes Decisions by the platform
that were often not necessarily
motivated by any um coherent principles
and the board has been studying this
since uh meta referred this to the board
for us to investigate and to publish an
opinion on how they should transform
that system this I think speaks to
exactly what you're talking about
whether there is this uh ice Berg of
things that we don't see behind the
scenes that end up having very
consequential impacts on free expression
around the world how we flag that in
public that is something which you know
raises obviously technical issues to it
to some extent also in some cases things
around privacy and and ethics for users
um but definitely from our side of the
house when we look at these cases we do
want to ensure we're not just going for
things that are driving the new cycle
and I think that also goes along with
not being super Western Centric
um the global media often takes its cues
in many ways from news outlets in Europe
and the United States and these are
things that often seem like they are the
most important issues for everyone but
they aren't thanks Dex Dex Hunter touric
thank you so much a fascinating topic
and what I'm sure we'll be talking about
in the weeks and months to come as we
see exactly what Elon Musk does at
Twitter